cette année
on est tous enfin on est tous dans le
même bateau
et si et si parfois ça déraille bas tout
le monde en pâtit disons mais mais voilà
après c'est sûr qu'il ya qui a des ratés
quand on les voit à l'écran c'est on se
dit bah pourquoi pourquoi avoir gardé ça
après moi je je veux je ne vois personne
à blâmer où tout le monde et puis après
c'est sûr que mon la réaction était j'ai
trouvé un peu disproportionné disons
parce que parce que c'est dur de devoir
de se voir résumer à ça et quand quand
voilà quand je compte fait du mieux que
je peux disons pour trouver
l'authenticité donc chaque personnage et
se voir résumé une scène ça pas été
forcément et par agréable odeur des bons
fait c'était madame c'est un mort dans
batman ses nus
après oui dans mais c'est sûr qu'il faut
à une fois il faut savoir rire de tout
et puis surtout enfin au delà d'avoir du
recul il ya des choses ramon plus grave
dans ma vie que ça même s'il ya des
choses qui peuvent blesser que et
mais bon ça n'a pas été ça n'a pas été
plus loin que j'ai pas été au bout du
rouleau bon plus quoi ce que j'ai juste
trouvé
j'ai juste trouvé la réaction
disproportionnée et puis et ça me fait
ça me fait du bien à moi la première
d'environ